après avoir voyagé 40 ans dans l'espace
quatre astronautes sont de retour sur
terre il n'y avait pas des forêts autour
de portland le monde qu'il connaissait a
changé le présente capitaine tchèque
buzz de l'armée de l'air des états unis
les aliens ont réduit les humains à
l'état d'esclave
vous qui êtes vous de quelle planète
venez-vous les termites ont envahi la
planète terre pour nous c'est votre
veulent exactement ces aliens les forêts
ils veulent notre pouvoir
il dessine lentement mais sûrement les
arbres de nos forêts le destin de la
planète est entre les mains d'un seul
homme non il devra combattre la tyrannie
délibéré la race humaine
ils peuvent mourir comme tout être
vivant il devra sauver le monde à lui
seul on va botter les fesses de ces
aliens on va libérer mon ami et tous les
esclaves du camp de travail
il est prêt à se battre avec moi
monsieur le président cette révolution a
besoin d'un chef
et puisque vous vous résignez je peux en
prendre la tête
son courage l'avait conduit à défier
l'armée des ténèbres mais le
conduira-t-il à la victoire suprême
non
aliens apocalypse vais vous en faire
bouffer du bois